300 families over 1 000 orphans are
going to benefit please help me reach my
target now
yes that's correct not only does it
encourage you to read it tells you how
many verses you've read how many pages
you read how long you've been on it and
best of all the hasanah counter download
the qurani app now and have a ramadan
with allah's book like you've never had
before
as a woman do you find a man more
attractive when he's
not talking
toxic masculinity yeah but as a woman do
you not find it a bit more attractive or
you know that's where a male's role is
uh you know decision making as well yeah
but in my family i actually
i'm from wales and i was one of eight so
i actually i do everything i decorate i
fix the car i do everything and my
ex-husband didn't uh he didn't think of
me and that sort of
in a way of being um somebody who can do
things because he was the clinician the
dentist so i was just somebody who was
stupid no i don't think you're stupid
i can do all those things i can fix
things i was the one that opened up our
dental practice i do all the decoration
i did all the equipment um no you look
like a very intelligent woman i don't
think anyone should call you that i can
see it from you natural
yeah you know i i say to people do you
think the word doctor comes from
indoctrination because they don't
actually think they just regurgitate
information like a parent yeah so would
you say those things that you were
forced to do is it because you chose
choose to do
i like to help people i want to look
after people i'm i'm the forever mum i
want to help people that's my goal
shouldn't your husband be doing some of
those things no he didn't do any of him
no no shouldn't he be doing it that's
why i said did he ask you to do it no i
think because he felt that he was
higher than me i was lower than him
because of his degree so we believe in
the sight of god almighty you are better
in degree in your closeness to god so
it's not about what degree you have
how pretty you are how handsome you are
what money you have please mean nothing
can i ask you something sister yeah yeah
sister yola yeah okay open the quran in
a random place and choose a birth
because this whole book is a message
which made our heirs to what is left by
parents and relatives
and to those whom our oaths have bonded
give them their share indeed allah is
is ever over all things a witness i
believe that do you know why let's read
that when i was going through bad times
in my life yes i started seeing love
hearts everywhere wow and i believe that
was my mum and dad from heaven sending
me their love because i believe their
spirit is with god now and he is there
looking after them and it's because they
were such good people that they actually
went to that level if people are bad
they have to come back and relive the
bad things until they learn that they've
got to be good before they can go to the
next level
as muslims we don't believe
reincarnation but this is a very
important verse you open so it says and
for all we have made it highest to what
is left by parents and relatives and to
those whom your office have bound to you
to give them their share indeed allah's
ever all things witness
men are in tribes this is very
interesting yeah because we were talking
about
this this is very interesting yeah
because we're talking about you know the
patriarchy etc in the household yeah men
are in charge of women by the right of
what allah has given one over the other
and what they spend of maintaining from
their wealth so so here is talking about
men should be the maintainers and
protectors of women so what that that
that means is for example that we are
like full-time bodyguards to our
relatives so this can be daughter sister
mother but that and this is so profound
that we are talking about this and look
at the verse you open it's talking
directly about that because me for
example like i'm giving myself something
i'm a good example but i have to provide
the rent i have to do the shopping i
have to give basic necessities to my
wife and uh when i married her she asked
for dowry do you know what diaries yes
yes so and she what did you give she
didn't give me a storm of granddaughter
so basically it was what she asked me
she gave me his complaint and she said
if i can't pay it she'll forgive me but
the point is the following we are the
maintainers and protectors of women and
that's her right i can't touch that
money so i have to provide for her and
and maintain her so if i'm walking down
the road and someone puts a knife out i
can't tell a dial and go and protect me
i have to do that yeah but today women
feel as if no
i can go and and there's nothing wrong
with earning by the way you know you're
you're a professional you're a
nutritionist yeah yeah but my no i own a
dental practice my nutrition i do as a
free i give free advice because i have
this just
i want to help people yeah i want to
make a difference i've got some
information why shouldn't i use it yes i
don't want to make a living from it i
want to help people yeah not exactly you
know and here like for example
it carries on so righteous women are
devoutly obedient guardian and their
husbands absent what allah would have
given them but those were so he talks
about for example also when there's a
conflict that's about to happen yeah so
for example
you